so yeah I want to talk to you about
algorithmic optimization but first a few
words about how I got to this point
I created a library called leaflet for
interactive maps nine years ago and in a
year since it became so mainstream that
you can see it everywhere on the
Internet
when there are mop maps and actually
sometimes I see it in Hollywood movies
like this is a real scene from the
equalizer where Denzel Washington stares
angrily at my open source library that
was really cool to see anyway so for the
last six years at my box I've been a
part of a team with a much more
ambitious goal of taking cartographic
technology and bringing it directly into
the browser where instead of loading
just map images you load raw data like
roads and buildings and rivers and parks
and processing that data on the fly on
the client and rendering it at 60 frames
per second which is a very difficult job
so of course we had to use all the
recent technologies like WebGL web
workers etc and some sophisticated
algorithms and it also required an
intense focus on performance
some people think of performance as
something that makes a difference in how
long the user waits first something to
happen after clicking on a button but in
many cases performance actually makes
the difference between something that
was never possible before and now you
can actually use it in a browser and
feels like magic
so yeah in in this case of vector
rendering it was either we we had to
make the frame rates stable so happy
making it as fast as possible or the map
wouldn't be usable at all so I weren't
quite a few tricks of how to write
extremely fast code in in the last
year's
and in any occasion where I could
extract this code that I wrote into a
standalone library I did so
so I released a few dozen libraries most
of them are very small and focused on
very specific one task like an algorithm
or data structure and to give you a few
examples this is the world's fastest
library for breaking down a polygon into
triangles which is important for WebGL
rendering then there's the fastest
library for generating a sprite layout I
wrote six different libraries for
spatial indexing which allows searching
geometric data really fast the fastest
library for visual regression testing
and this is my latest this is
approximation of terrains with triangle
rashes but and when you work on this
kind of stuff you sometimes get very
competitive you want your ivory to be
faster than all the others and sometimes
seeking out really ridiculous
my favorite was a example that is Dylan
a triangulation
so Dylan a triangulation as an a similar
concept Voronoi diagram is a fundamental
algorithm in computational geometry
which is extremely useful for data
visualization and let's take a look at a
sample of running down a triangulation
on 1 million points in JavaScript 1
million is quite a big amount for
JavaScript right even by today's
standards so in the beginning there was
a library called simply delay you can
find it in NPM and it performed this
task in 2 minutes 30 seconds some
someone thought that ha this is not fast
enough for my needs so I I can write
something faster and they made a library
called delay fast and you wasn't it much
faster but someone else came try it
using it and thought hmm
this is called fast but it's not
actually fast I need it faster so can
you guess what the library name faster
than one a and it was a huge
groundbreaking change because it was
like 20 to 30 times faster which is huge
but it was too too fun for me to pass on
such an opportunity and I tried writing
my own library for this and I was
tempted to call it the fastest doing it
but I would embarrass myself because
someone else will come up to me and
write something faster so I called it
donator it's five times faster than the
previous one and the interesting thing
about it is that the community tried
porting it to C++ and it's just a little
bit faster than the JavaScript version
then I got interested in rust and as a
learning project I tried pouring in this
algorithm to rust and it was also just a
little bit faster so the point here is
that if you write your Java Script very
carefully with like algorithmic thinking
in mind it can approach native speeds so
you might think that you need a kind of
a computer science degree to work on
that kind of stuff but the fact is that
by the time I dropped out of university
I still knew nothing about algorithms
and data structures I had to learn this
from scratch and so can you
this is my student time this is actually
me 15 years ago in a low-budget gothic
metal music video that's the type of
stuff I did back then and sometimes do
today too
so how to make fast code you three steps
very simple find a bottleneck something
that's actually the slowest part and try
to understand why it's all and then make
it faster
okay I'm done
so these is step is finding a bottleneck
because modern tooling for profiling is
amazing it's so much easier to find out
what is slow in your application that
then even like two years ago it wasn't
as awesome as it is now the tools are
great you just like record something
that's slow with for example chrome dev
tools profiler and then you drill down
through the code and you and then you
find a function that's taking all the
time taking much more time than needed
and then you open it up in your editor
and you stare at it for hours and don't
know what to do so those two steps
understand why it slow and make it
faster this has a lot to do about
algorithms and I'll try to make a gentle
introduction and the most important
definition to make about slow code and
optimization is that slow code is code
that does unnecessary work is the code
that does more than you need for a
particular task so our job as someone
who optimizes code is to find useless
crap and remove it so we'll jump into a
practical example roll up is one of my
favorites open-source projects I use it
in all my libraries and it's an amazing
JavaScript bundler that's used by pretty
much all library authors like in react
babel stencil you name it so um I used
it a lot and wanted it to be faster and
at some point I started looking into
optimizing it and found out that one of
the foulest part was generating source
maps so I profiled it and narrowed it
down to two lines of code one line of
code use its use dependency code magic
string to generate a source map then the
second
Lyonne decoded this string into an
object to manipulate its later and
source maps look like this this there
look like a string so you can't really
understand why it's all because there's
dependency and you have to walk inside
and figure out what's going on so I
looked into it and what magic string
actually did it did some magic generated
a source map you know as a JSON object
and then it encoded it into this special
string representation then on the row
upside we took the string and we decoded
it into adjacent to manipulate later and
at this point when the code is presented
like this you may immediately can notice
what's wrong with this code right so
these two lines of code they're
absolutely useless you take some data
convert it into a different format and
then you immediately convert it back and
you never needed that other format in
the first place so it's very hard to
notice this kind of problems when those
lines of code are in different functions
but when they're in different files it's
even harder when they are in different
projects altogether it's super difficult
so when you optimize code you always
need to be aware for like what happens
in your dependencies so after removing
those two lines of code it got a source
map generation guys porchetta of 40%
faster now to understand more complex
use cases optimisation you need to earn
the concept of algorithmic complexity
which is a measure of how performance
scales with input size and you probably
know what all those things mean but
we'll just assume that you know nothing
about it and I'll try to arrange reduce
rule to it from scratch so the first
category of algorithm complexity is
called constant complexity o1 it's when
regardless of how big your data input is
you have to perform a constant number of
operations and
is the best category because you don't
have to worry about it at all
usually the bottleneck isn't there you
don't have to deal with it it's just
fast then there's the next category
linear complexity oh and and you can
easily spot it if there's a loop in your
code and this category will call it
suspicious because linear complexity can
easily grow into much slower
complexities and I'll show you how so
the next category is au n squared which
are so-called quadratic complexity you
can spot it for example when you have
nested for loops and this complexity
means your code is ridiculously slow and
this is a sign that you can optimize it
a lot usually but by this point this is
slow code and it's easy to spot it when
you you see just like two loops together
but sometimes it's not obvious at all
like you see one loop you think this is
litter then it turns out that's a native
browser method index off is that is also
in our complexity and when nested they
become the quadratic complexity and this
is slow and many people don't even think
about performance of native methods they
just assume that everyone optimize them
maximally and they are just fast but if
you're not aware of the complexity it
can grow into really really small code
and sometimes it's not obvious because
those complexities are on different
methods or in different dependencies
it's etc so and it's such a common
problem that there's even a separate
block block about it
code accidentally quadratic it's a
serious engineering block that looks
into problems with performance in really
big projects like elasticsearch react
etc so this is a very common problem and
very easy to hit then if you have
cube three nested loops you just throw
it out you is beyond saving
so we'll look into another practical
example and I forgot to mention that
every time you see this like the name of
the repository and the number this is a
pull request you can look up and see
what's actually happened so this was a
code in d3 library that was slow and you
don't have to like read and understand
what's happening so and I didn't
understand what it happens here too
I just I noticed one loop uh-huh
this is suspicious so I looked further
and I noticed another loop inside and
that's already very slow and then I
looked further and I know this splice
which is also a winner complexity
operation and that means you throw it
out and you write it from scratch and
that's what I did and it became many
times faster so you have to be
suspicious anytime you use native array
methods because they are winner
complexity oh the index of include
splice etc but so far I've talked about
computational complexity but there's
also another expected performance which
is memory complexity and if we say about
slow code as through the dust and
necessary work in terms of memory
it means you allocate much more memory
than you need and this is a also a
problem so every time you use things
like slice concat map and filter or
string split you allocate new arrays new
memory and sometimes you don't need that
and getting rid of that makes code
faster so this kind of style of
programming that's usually it's called
like functional style programming by
some if it's in a hot bath and you need
to squeeze the last bit of performance
out of it you you have to avoid it
because in this case you allocate memory
and throw it out immediately four times
and this is just like it's an s3 work
and even in small cases like JavaScript
doesn't have a way to return multiple
values so what usually
do is you define an array return that
and if you immediately the structure the
values and don't eat this as an array
you just performed an unnecessary work
because you didn't need this needed
disarray so in hard paths you have to be
mindful of those kinds of things like
this
so another practical example I really
love source map so this is also about
source maps this is a dependency of row
up to that's performed decoding of of
the string into a source map so what I
did before
is it split the string into array of
strings each representing a line that
for each line is split the line into an
array of segments then for each segment
it decoded it into an array of coin
points and did something about it
now we know that if we have three nested
loops we need to write this from scratch
so the poor requests made it so that we
process decoding in a streaming fashion
we go character by character and do
something depending on which character
we encounter it and this doesn't need
any allocation at all and this mate is
just one loop no location and it's three
times faster so I haven't talked about
logarithmic complexity yet but it's the
best complexity and you understand why
because well intuitively when you think
about this range of complexities from
constant to winner you think about
logarithmic ins as something in the
middle but actually is somewhere here it
means it's blazing fast so if you have
an array of million points logarithmic
operation will take twenty operations
it's very fast so the classic example
that is binary search and usually like
you never think about it it's just
something that you get asked on code
interviews and then never use in
practice but once you actually try to
I'm just
and how to use it it kind of clicks in
your head and then you can start seeing
it everywhere so binary search is really
easy to explain so if you have sorted
sorted array and you don't need to fight
something inside you just at every point
you throw out half of the items so we
look at the middle the the item that we
want to find this in the left half we
threw it out so at each point we throw
out half of the items and we find our
item very fast so this is another Bua
quest to roll up where a particular
build was taking many minutes with
source maps and just a few seconds
without source maps so we're writing a
particular code to use binary search
made it 40 times faster so I'm going to
think optimization when you optimize
code you try to reduce the complexity
but how do you actually do that the way
I like to think about it is that you
have some very slow operation and you
repeat it several times the way to make
it fast and reduce algorithmic
complexity is to organize data in some
way that allows you to perform all these
subsequent operations much faster so do
more in the beginning to do less every
next time and do you organize data you
have all kinds of data structures but it
doesn't have to be complicated actually
my favorite data structure is just the
sorted array it also organizes your data
in a certain way and you can operate on
it much faster if you know know what
what you're doing so for example one of
my library is Katie Bush for searching
geometric points is just a fancy sorted
array where when you sort taking tour
turns by horizontally or vertically and
it allows searching the points instantly
even do is just an array
which was sorted and the last point I
want to make is that sometimes it's not
enough to be mindful of what happens in
your dependencies sometimes you need to
think about what happens on the
JavaScript engine level so you have two
objects here and they look the same so
you think that they are represented in
the same way in the engine but one
starts with one in the key 1 2 3 and
it's a hash table if it starts with 1
you think says a generic keys and the
other one starts with 0 and it's it's
not different from an array it's pretty
much the same thing so it gets
represented the same way so there's a
test coverage utility named Nick New
York which was previously Istanbul
project and this test coverage
instrumentation was taking a very long
time like many many minutes we wanted to
optimize that too to generate this test
coverage information there there's a
stat subject that keeps track of which
line of code God executed and it keeps
track of this in an object with keys
like one is for the line the first one
to use for the second line etc and
simply changing this indexing from to
start with zero it made test coverage 15
times faster and this was mind-blowing
to me because this is a project that was
used by the community for years and like
no one had an idea that it could be made
15 times faster by just changing one one
line of code so the point is that people
take a stable code for granted but there
are lots of opportunities for
optimization and you can always find
some room for improvement so I encourage
you to learn how things work under the
hood don't be afraid to reinvent the
wheel simplify your code constantly
because it's easier to optimize and
practice optimization and you'll learn
how to write pass code by default okay
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]